that was the silver lining to the
quarantine they had to come home New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo is opening up
about the bright spots of quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic I have my
three girls with me Cara Mariah Mikayla
they were forced to come home you know
they're in their early 20s so the
hanging out with dad is not super cool
right now but that was the silver lining
to the quarantine they had to come home
the 62 year old joined Jimmy Fallon on
The Tonight Show Home Edition Wednesday
and explained that he's spending his
time with his daughters whom he shares
with his ex-wife Kerry Kennedy they were
in their early twenties the last thing
they wanted to do is hang out with that
and they were out there living their
lives and in a crazy way this gave me
time with them that I would have never
had you know so that's been great and
when Jimmy brought up the fact that
terms like Cuomo crush and Cuomo sexual
are actually a thing now Andrew laughed
it off and said he's not letting it get
to his head I enjoy using it selectively
certain friends and family actually and
those people who are saying good things
it's only because they don't know me
Jimmy but they get to know me they have
a much different somehow
I doubt that's true between Andrew and
his brother CNN anchor Chris Cuomo
there's a whole lot of Cuomo to love
we're talking about my brother talking
about my little brother this is my best
friend back in April a source close to
Chris told et the brothers are aware of
the Cuomo crush and hashtag Cuomo
brothers they think it's cute and
playful
I've never been prouder of you than I am
right now the source jokingly added
quote although Chris doesn't understand
why people think Andrew is so handsome
my pop would be proud I love you little
brother and even though this isn't a
flattering picture
I did not pick this picture with your
mouth open but it is
suitable in some ways among those Cuomo
supporters Governor Cuomo Jada
pinkett-smith who admitted during a
recent episode of red Tabletalk that the
governor is her celebrity crush I don't
miss a press conference when Cuomo's on
I'm hurt I'm like got to go see my
celebrity crush right now sorry Trevor
Noah is also a self-proclaimed Cuomo
sexual there's a group of women who came
out and they said we we're falling in
love with Cuomo and I said well yeah
everyone
everyone said we have homosexual in that
way in April et caught up with Randy
rainbow the comedian who coined the term
Cuomo sexual and he explained his love
for the politician it's just sort of
been an instant love affair with them
now mind you prior to that it was a very
serious thing I had going with Chris
it wasn't mutual to my knowledge but it
was very serious for me
et also caught up with Chris's wife
Christina to talk about her magazine
purist but of course she also weighed in
on all the love her hubby and
brother-in-law are getting on TV yeah
they're always taking digs at each other
and it's hilarious and it always
provides for entertainment that family
functions and they love each other to
death Chris learned a lot from him and
you know they kind of finish each other
sentences and you know they you know
they ingest and it's it's provides for a
lot of entertainment it's really nice
that they're sharing it with everyone
else now so gars feel a little relief
from their anxiety through some humor
I've seen so many people commenting
saying you know we love them we love the
brotherly love and yes they're cute that
hashtag Cuomo crush did you guys see
that now they've become he's heartthrob
and the Cuomo sectional t-shirts yeah
they're hilarious I love them I have
someone sending me a sweater that says
that and then I had I mean it then we
should get some masks
right
[Music]